tag zusammen herzlich willkommen zu zdf
heute live kein grad weiter sonst wird
richtig ungemütlich dann ungemütlich
wird es sowieso werden das ist ja so
ganz ganz grob zusammengefasst die
aussage des berichts den der
zwischenstaatlichen ausschuss für
klimaänderungen so heißt er im deutschen
übersetzt etc etc
auch bekannt als weltklimarat heute
vorgestellt hat und der bericht ist der
erste teil des sechsten
sachstandsberichts den der pcc seit ein
paar jahren herausgibt und beschäftigt
sich erst mal mit der
naturwissenschaftlichen frage nämlich
was ist eigentlich jetzt der
wissenschaftliche kenntnisstand zu dem
was hier zum klimawandel wissen und was
können wir daraus ableiten wie drastisch
kann das ganze für uns werden dafür
haben die wissenschaftlerinnen tausende
von fachpublikationen durchforstet
zusammengefasst zu diesem bericht wer
das ergebnis sprechen wird leicht mit
einer der hauptautoren das ist dr
friedrich otto physikerin klimatologin
und geschäftsführerin des environmental
change instituts der universität oxford
außerdem hat sie ein buch geschrieben
mit dem schönen titel wütendes wetter
und damit kennt sich auch mein anderer
gast meiner gestern sagt man nicht mein
gast im studio aus katja hornuf az der
theologin hüten das wetter kennst du
auch na ja kennen wir fragen den
kommentare wie immer bei uns in die
dafür vorgesehenen kommentarspalten oder
ans zdf heute.de zdf.de
wir gucken was wir da mit rein nehmen
aber bevor wir in die details gehen hat
an seinem stern das ganze mal kurz für
uns zusammengefasst fluten und flammen
hitze und dürre extrem ist die lage an
vielen orten der welt schon jetzt in
diesem sommer noch dramatischer könnte
sie werden in der zukunft denn die erde
heizt sich auf immer schneller so der
bericht bereits in den jahren um 2030
rechnet der weltklimarat mit einem
globalen temperaturanstieg um 1,5 grad
im vergleich zum vorindustriellen
zeitalter 2030 das wäre ein jahrzehnt
früher als bislang angenommen
die folgen lebensgefährliche wetterlagen
öfter und heftiger enorme hitze wählen
könnten alle zehn jahre kommen im
schnitt statt die bislang etwa alle 50
jahre dazu stärkere stürme und
überschwemmungen
der anstieg des meeresspiegels und das
abschmelzen der eisschollen in der
arktis schon jetzt unumkehrbar heißt es
die wissenschaftler machen klar all das
ist menschengemacht 2009 10 war laut
bericht so viel klimaschädliches co2 in
der atmosphäre wie noch nie in den
vergangenen zwei millionen jahren
ja und darüber sprechen wir jetzt mit
doktor kredite otto einer der
hauptautoren dieses berichts physikerin
klimatologin habe ich gerade schon
vorgestellt ganz grundsätzlich frau dr
otto was steht in diesem bericht was
haben sie da zusammengefasst was die
klimaforschung nicht eh schon seit
jahren predigt der klimawandel ist
menschengemacht liegt am co2 ausstoß den
wir so produzieren und wenn wir nicht
schnell was tun dann saufen wir alle an
diesen grundsätzlichen tatsachen hat
sich natürlich nichts geändert aber es
gibt schon eine ganze menge neue
wissenschaftliche erkenntnisse die in
den letzten acht jahren seit der
veröffentlichung des letzten
sachstandsbericht entstanden sind und
einer ein bereich ist zum beispiel die
die forschung zu extremwetter
ereignissen
wir wissen jetzt und das sagt dieser
bericht auch ganz deutlich dass in allen
regionen der welt
der klimawandel wetter und klima
ereignisse verändert hat dass somit vor
allem auf diesen regionalen stahl gab
konnte man das vor acht jahren noch
nicht sagen
und dann bei vielen sachen die wir im
prinzip schon wussten hat sich auch
einfach die sicherheit oder die dass das
vertrauen dass wir in unsere farben
deutlich erhöhen und dazu gehört zum
beispiel auch dass das zum beispiel wenn
wir aufhören fossile brennstoffe zu
verbrennen und nett null emissionen
in die atmosphäre bringen das dann
tatsächlich auch die temperatur aufhört
zu steigen
das war vor acht jahren noch relativ
unsicher weil natürlich auch prozesse
wie zum beispiel dass weitere auftaut
des permafrosts dazu hätten führen
können dass die temperatur auch mit null
emissionen weiter steigt aber das ist
eben nicht der fall
woran liegt das dass wir das jetzt so
genauer wissen als vor acht jahren sind
die methoden die wissenschaftlichen
methoden besser geworden haben wir mehr
daten gesammelt
oder hat sich tatsächlich in den acht
jahren im klima so viel verändert dass
man das besser nachverfolgen kann von
allem etwas
wir haben natürlich was wir in diesen
acht jahren auch gesehen haben und das
ist gehört zu denen den wirklich
schlechten nachrichten die in diesem
bericht stehen wir haben wir haben ja
bisher keinerlei umkehr den
treibhausgasausstoß die
treibhausgasemissionen sind immer weiter
gestiegen
das hat dazu geführt dass also auch die
das nicht nur die erwärmung steigt
sondern eben auch die rate der erwärmung
so hoch ist wie seit mindestens 2000
jahren nicht mehr und das hat natürlich
zur folge dass in den letzten acht
jahren wir deutliche temperaturerhöhung
gesehen haben und deutliche veränderung
auch in extremwetterereignissen gesehen
haben das heißt das dass es gibt einfach
mehr klimawandel als noch vor acht
jahren das aber es gibt auch zu
verschiedenen bereichen mehr forschung
und mehr daten also mehr daten zum einen
eben weil der klimawandel weiter
fortgeschritten ist aber auch weil viel
mühe in den letzten jahren reingesteckt
wurde historische wetterdaten zu retten
zu digitalisieren mit in die in
wissenschaftlichen studien zu
untersuchen
das heißt wir haben also bessere
verständnis davon wie sich der krise wie
sich das klima über die letzten 100
jahre entwickelt hat und dann was in
diesem bericht auch neu ist ist das eben
die ganzen verschiedenen beweisführung
linien oder beweis linien die wir haben
also zum einen
beobachtungsdaten zum anderen halt
physikalische theorie und physikalisches
verständnis und eben auch verschiedenste
klimamodelle alle zusammen zu bestimmten
phänomen analysiert werden und wir eben
diese ganzen beweis linien alle
zusammenführen und damit dadurch hat
sich auch die uns unser wissensstand
verbessert zu vielen dieser bereiche und
eine letzte sache die ich noch kurz
sagen möchte was in diesem bericht auch
ein großer fortschritt ist es über 40
prozent der autoren sind aus dem
globalen süden aus entwicklungsländern
und damit bringen die natürlich auch
ganz ganz andere ganz andere art
wissenschaft zu machen mit mit in diesem
bericht rein aber eben auch geht es gibt
es auch viel mehr wissenschaft eben aus
dem globalen süden und über den globalen
süden
es gibt zwar immer noch viel weniger als
als jetzt in den hochentwickelten
ländern aber auch da haben sich
wissenslücken geschlossen
bevor wir weiterreden ein kurzes wort
von mir an unsere zuschauer innen an die
community besonders jetzt auf youtube
wer hier unsere gesprächspartnerin
beleidigt oder irgendwie unflätig wird
der fliegt natürlich sofort raus und
wird dementsprechend auch blockiert auch
dinge die jetzt irgendwie relativ
unwissenschaftlich sind lesen sie hier
nehmen wir hin ist nur meinungsäußerung
müssen aber einfach sagen die
wissenschaft deckt das nicht die
wissenschaftlichen erkenntnissen die von
vielen vielen hunderttausenden von
wissenschaftlern erforscht werden können
einfach mittlerweile bestätigen
der klimawandel ist menschengemacht
meine frage an sie in diese richtung sie
werden damit ja auch häufig konfrontiert
mit mit zweifeln
was entgegnen sie in so einem so einem
fall wenn sie so etwas lesen die hier
zum beispiel es gibt keinen menschen
gemachten klimawandel dass der
menschengemachte klimawandel beruht auf
der tatsache dass auf den chemischen und
physikalischen eigenschaften von
treibhausgas molekül
diese chemischen eigenschaften führen
dazu dass die moleküle langwellige
strahlung absorbieren und sich damit die
atmosphäre erhöht
das ist dazu braucht man keine
klimamodelle um das haus zu finden
das ist ganz ganz grundlegende physik
und chemie und wer an grundlegender
physik zweifelt dem kann ich dann auch
nicht helfen aber der hat dann auch
wirklich große schwierigkeiten im alltag
wenn er diese dieser art von zweifel an
alle anderen physikalischen
zusammenhänge auch an denen würde zum
beispiel unseres gespräch also was wir
hier machen und dass wir senden ist ja
auch alles im grunde pure physik jetzt
haben sie gerade schon gesagt die gute
nachricht ist dass wenn wir die
treibhausgasemissionen sofort stoppen
würden also auf netto null nennen sie
das immer runter fahren
dass sich dann die welt oder das weckt
die man nicht weiter aufheizen würde das
ist er ist eine relativ unrealistische
annahme sie haben bayer verschiedene
modelle vorgestellt die entweder relativ
unrealistisch sind oder quasi davon
ausgehen dass wir so weiter machen die
bis jetzt mit den klima klimagasausstoß
oder dass wir den senken
welche von diesen szenarien sind dann
tatsächlich jetzt so worauf wir uns
vorbereiten müssen also was ist quasi
das was in den nächsten 100 jahren
vermutlich nach stand der wissenschaft
jetzt auf uns zukommen wird
also was in diesem teil des berichts
analysiert sind die
naturwissenschaftlichen tatsache und die
naturwissenschaftlichen erkenntnisse und
um diese zu untersuchen haben wir fünf
attraktive szenarien verwendet und diese
szenarien sind bestehen also machen
treffen annahmen über mögliche plausible
entwicklungen die sich ökonomisch und
sozial die welt verändern kann und dann
welche treibhausgasemissionen diese
sozial und sozialen und ökonomischen
veränderungen zur folge haben und diese
treibhausgasemissionen aus diesen
verschiedenen fünf verschiedenen
szenarien nehmen wir dann als grundlage
in diesem ersten teil des berichts um
eben zugucken wie verändert sich die
welt das heißt in diesem bericht werden
keinerlei annahmen darüber getroffen
welches davon wahrscheinlich eintreten
wird oder nicht
diese diese und andere szenarien und
eben die die ökonomischen grundlagen und
lösungsmöglichkeiten
die werden im dritten teil des berichts
analysiert und vorgestellt der im märz
erscheint also füllt von den
naturwissenschaftlichen seite die wir
uns hier jetzt geben angeguckt haben
sind alle fünf szenarien plausibel und
es gibt eben eins das hat sehr niedrige
emissionen
die würden wir ein solches szenario
würde man dann einhalten können
wenn wir jetzt wirklich sofort und
drastisch global die co2-emissionen
reduzieren und zwar nachhaltig und so
weit reduzieren dass sie eben bis mitte
des jahrhunderts auf netto 0 10 vom vom
physikalischen standpunkt ist das
möglich andere szenarien die wir
angeguckt haben sind eben die die führen
dazu dass dass sich das klima auf zwei
grad erwärmt oder eben bei dem hoch
emissionsszenario auch auf bis zu 4 grad
zum ende des jahrhunderts der wende
frage von caron
welche naheliegenden kipp punkte sind
aus ihrer sicht die am meisten
bedrohlichen ich habe jetzt auch schon
stimmen gehört die sagten kipp punkte
gibt es diese überhaupt also gibt es
tatsächlich einen punkt wo man sagen
muss okay das ist ein point of no return
wenn sich bis dahin das und das
verändert hat dann wird es nicht wieder
in naher zukunft in den zustand davor
zurück kommen
also es gibt elemente im klimasystem und
eins davon ist zum beispiel die die
meere die atlantische meridiane strömung
die allgemein hin als golfstrom
bezeichnet wird der diese strömung hat
zwei zustände eines der den wir jetzt
beobachten
der kann aber auch sich so ändern dass
das warme wasser was zurzeit in die vom
vom golf rüber ins wenn die europäischen
gewässer kommen
eben nicht mehr fließt das ist ein
anderes element ist zum beispiel dass
der amazonischen regenwald sich in eine
steppe verwandeln könnte diese
kippelemente gibt es im klimasystem ist
ein ganz spezielle elemente also zum
beispiel das 15 grad ziel oder so ist
absolut kein cap element das ist ein
politisches ziel
und in diesem bericht werden auch kipp
punkte analysiert in dem darunter
liegenden arbeiten und auch in der
zusammenfassung die heute veröffentlicht
wurde gibt es dazu statements und das
ist auch eine der guten nachrichten die
diese bericht hat denn wir können zwar
bisher bei der erwärmung die wir jetzt
haben nicht ausschließen dass diese
kippelemente schon kipp punkte erreicht
haben aber die wahrscheinlichkeit dafür
ist nach heutigem wissenstand sehr
gering und wird auch wenn wir die
bewerbung auf zb 15 grad oder oder ein
bisschen drüber begrenzen gering bleiben
aber mit höhere erwärmung ist wird die
wäsche nimmt die wahrscheinlichkeit sehr
deutlich zu dass ebensolche kipp punkte
erreicht werden und dann diese
kippelemente tatsächlich kippen könnten
was also zum beispiel jetzt mit dem
golfstrom dramatische folgen hätte für
das wetter in mitteleuropa
jetzt gucken wir uns gleich nochmal
detailliert an mit meiner kollegin katja
horneffer ein argument was wir hier
häufig auch im chat lesen gerade als es
um die starkregen ereignisse in
nordrhein westfalen und rheinland pfalz
ging war immer ja schlechtes wetter gab
es immer schon aus der politik gab es
ähnliche stimmen
in der vergangenheit war es immer
schwierig zu sagen ob jetzt ein
bestimmtes ereignis was mit dem
klimawandel zu tun hat oder nicht dann
wurde immer so ein bisschen ja ich sag
mal laviert und gesagt okay es gibt
einfach mehr von diesen ereignissen
durch den klimawandel
sie haben eine neue forschungsrichtung
mitgegründet die nennt sich zu ordnungs
forschung was versteht man darunter oder
was verstehen sie darunter genau
also die zuordnung forschung versucht
die frage zu beantworten ob und wenn ja
wie sehr der menschengemachte
klimawandel die wahrscheinlichkeit und
intensität für bestimmte
extremwetterereignisse verändert hat
denn natürlich stimmt es dass es schon
immer extrem wetter gegeben hat und es
gibt auch ohne klimawandel extremwetter
1 aber was der klimawandel macht für
bestimmte nicht alle werte ereignisse
eben die wahrscheinlichkeit und
intensität zu verändern und zum beispiel
bei hitzewellen ist das besonders
dramatisch also die wahrscheinlichkeit
für hitzewellen ist ist überall auf der
welt eigentlich aufgrund des
klimawandels deutlich höher geworden und
auch hitzewellen die jetzt auftreten
sind deutlich heißer als sie es ohne den
klimawandel gewesen wären für starkregen
ereignisse sehen wir dass die
wahrscheinlichkeit auf in vielen teilen
der welt auch bereits zugenommen hat
aber deutlich geringer also während zum
beispiel hitzewellen 10 hundert oder
sogar tausend mal wahrscheinlicher
geworden sind in verschiedenen regionen
ist es bei starkregenfällen eher so dass
sich die die wahrscheinlichkeit ungefähr
verdoppelt hat und bei dürren ist es
auch so dass sich die wahrscheinlichkeit
in verschiedenen bereichen der welt aber
eben nicht in allen sondern vor allem in
den regionen die sowieso schon relativ
trocken sind auch erhöht hat und in der
zuordnung forschung untersuchen wir eben
individuelle extremereignisse und
benutzten beobachtungsdaten und
statistische modelle und auch
verschiedene klimamodelle um zum einen
festzustellen was für ein ereignis ist
das in der welt in der wir heute leben
es ist ein jahrhundertereignis oder ist
es ein zehnjahres ereignis und dann da
wir sehr genau wissen wie viele
treibhausgase seit beginn der
industriellen revolution in die
atmosphäre gelangt sind können wir diese
in den verschiedenen klimamodellen aus
der atmosphäre rausholen und damit die
welt simulieren wie sie ohne klima aber
an die gewesen wäre und dann feststellen
wieder frei
ist es hat sich die wahrscheinlichkeit
verändert ist es immer noch ein
jahrhundertereignis dann hat sich das
diese art von ereignis durch den
klimawandel bisher nicht verändert
aber wenn zb etwas was jetzt ein
zehnjahres ereignisses ohne den
klimawandel ein jahrhundert ereignis
gewesen wäre
dann kann man eben diesen unterschied
diesen faktor 10 dem klimawandel
zuordnen und das ist das was die die
attributs ions forschung oder die
zuordnung forschung macht die jetzt auch
zum ersten mal in diesem sechsten
sachstandsbericht in einem report
analysiert wurde können sie denn schon
irgendeine aussage treffen zudem stark
ereignis was wir hier vor wenigen wochen
hatten in nordrhein westfalen und
rheinland pfalz arbeiten wir noch dran
ja da kann ich noch keine quantitative
aussage zu treffen jetzt habe ich hier
noch eine frage von einer zuschauerin
von andrea drexelius auf facebook die
möchte wissen frau dr otto glauben sie
persönlich dass wir das noch in den
griff bekommen passt so ein bisschen
auch in die frage von ruth dietmar
schweige man auch auf facebook was für
chancen gibt es dass die großen
industriestaaten jetzt gemeinsam
loslegen das was man unbedingt wissen
muss was der pc ist es ist ja nicht eine
ein zusammenschluss von von
wissenschaftlern sondern der pc ist ein
zusammenschluss besteht aus 195
regierungen auf dieser welt das heißt
alle im prinzip alle regierungen dieser
welt sind teil des pcs und in den
letzten zwei wochen haben wir
wissenschaftler die den bericht
beschrieben haben mit diesen regierung
zusammen gesessen und sind jeden satz
der zusammenfassung für
entscheidungsträger durchgegangen und
haben die wissenschaft dahinter erklärt
haben erklärt warum welche erkenntnisse
da so stehen und andere nicht und am
ende dieser zwei wochen haben alle
regierungen diesen bericht mit
unterschrieben und damit ist es
natürlich ein ganz anderes dokument als
jetzt einfach eine wissenschaftliche
studie
das heißt alle regierung wissen ganz
genau was getan werden muss was der
zustand des klimas ist dann sind wir
gespannt ob sich da auch was tut frau dr
otto vielen dank für den zeitpunkt jetzt
wir werden über das thema die nächsten
jahre auf jeden fall noch viel reden
hoffentlich auch mit ihnen und dann
schauen uns auch mal an wie in
deutschland die politik auf diesen
bericht reagiert hat da gibt es nämlich
einige stimmen die überschwemmungen in
deutschland haben gezeigt dass der
klimawandel auch bei uns kein
zukunftsthema mehr ist sondern realität
klimaschutz sei eine
überlebensnotwendige aufgabe so die
umweltministerin
die aber noch zu schaffen sein der
weltklimarat sagt erstmal ganz eindeutig
dass diese klimaveränderung menschen
gemacht sind das heißt da keinen zweifel
gibt und das ist sehr wichtig weil das
bedeutet wir können auch gegen steuern
und auch das sagt dieser bericht wenn
die nächsten zehn jahre genutzt werden
um eben treibhausgase zu reduzieren
dann kann man auch die erderwärmung noch
wieder in den griff bekommen in einer
sondersitzung des nordrhein
westfälischen landtags zum hochwasser
sprich der ministerpräsident und
kanzlerkandidat der union von
langjährigen anstrengungen konkret wird
er aber nicht wir müssen heute ist der
bericht des weltklimarates gekommen
auch bei der klimapolitik das ziel die
erderwärmung so niedrig wie möglich zu
halten
deutlich unter zwei grad besser 1,5 grad
weiter auf allen ebenen arbeiten
das ist eine aufgabe die über den tag
hinaus geht die grünen sehen alle ihre
befürchtungen bestätigt und werfen der
regierung große versäumnisse vor
fünf jahre hat diese bundesregierung
vertrödelt hat eben nicht die windräder
gebaut die wir brauchen
und jetzt gibt es keine ausreden mehr
wir wissen jetzt ins handeln kommen beim
klimaschutz 1 sich die afg glaubt nicht
an den menschengemachten klimawandel
wir wissen alle dass das was geplant
wird für deutschland am klimawandel
nichts ändern wird es wird nur
arbeitsplätze und wohlstand kosten
der dramatische bericht des
weltklimarates dürfte dem bisher recht
farblosen wahlkampf in deutschland neuen
treibstoff geben ja unter anderem
darüber rede ich jetzt mit meiner
kollegin katja hall faz der theologin
die auch schon lange das klima und das
wetter für uns beobachtet wetter und
klima gehören jetzt zusammen aber das
eine ist nicht immer durch das andere
das haben wir jetzt auch schon gelernt
jetzt mal aus seiner perspektive wie
bewertest du den bericht des
weltklimarates also jetzt dieser erste
bericht der im endeffekt haben ja zu
einer großen zu einem großen
sachstandsbericht zusammengefasst wird
also ich denke für die meisten
wissenschaftler wissenschaftlerinnen
waren jetzt da keine riesen großen
überraschungen drin
es hat ja gerade frau dr otto sehr
deutlich gemacht hast einfach noch mal
mehr daten da sind und dass man einfach
noch mal genauer hinschauen kann und ich
denke dass wichtig ist einfach dass
vielen menschen vielleicht immer noch
nicht klar ist dass es diese
kippelemente diese kipp punkte gibt wo
plötzlich etwas sich gravierend ändern
kann
ich vergleiche das immer ganz gerne mit
der resonanz katastrophe bei brücken
also wenn eine brücke anfängt zu
schwingen und dann passierte lange zeit
nichts und ganz plötzlich wenn die
richtige frequenz erreicht wird dann
geht sie kaputt und sie geht dann auch
nicht die wird man nicht einfach wieder
aufbauen können
das heißt solche kippelemente im klima
wenn die einmal zerstört sind dann
kommen wir in ein neues zustand ja es
gibt auch jetzt schon einige sachen die
einfach kaputt sind und sprechen wir von
den korallenriffen am great barrier reef
die sind schon so irreversibel zerstört
das auch wenn die wassertemperatur jetzt
sinken würde
die sich wahrscheinlich nicht mehr
regenerieren können
und einer von diesen kipp punkten hat
frau dr otto eben auch schon kurz
angesprochen oder du hast sie danach
gefragt ist eben auch der golfstrom der
golfstrom ein arm der atlantischen mehr
regionalen umwelt zirkulation der eben
bei uns weil wärme sorgt okay das letzte
wort habe ich fast nicht mehr die ersten
begriffe der atlantische mehr regionale
an sich heißt es im englischen dover
turning für umwelt und dann circulation
deswegen amok
also abgekürzt a m o c und ein 1 1 ein
arm dieser amok ist eben der golfstrom
der für uns dafür sorgt dass es in
mitteleuropa in großbritannien häufig
mild ist und wir eigentlich sind
abhängig von dieser warmwasser heizung
haben es gerade eben schon mal kurz
gehört das ist einfach der strom der von
der karibik vom golf von mexiko deswegen
golfstrom zu uns rüber den atlantik über
strömt und wir haben aber schon seit
vielen jahrzehnten festgestellt dass
sich dieser golfstrom immer mehr
abschwächt und jetzt gab es eine neue
studie die mit dem pc gar nichts zu tun
hat dass es eigentlich mehr eine
zufällige koinzidenz dass die ende
letzter woche raus kam vom
potsdam-institut für folgen forschung
das eben tatsächlich hier an dieser amok
an dieser atlantischen mehr regional
rover turning circulation sich ein
dramatischer kipp punkt andeutet der
vielleicht in absehbarer zeit erreicht
wird und das hätte dramatische folgen
für uns ich glaube wir haben auch eine
kleine grafik wir haben jetzt sollen wir
uns die anschauen das machen genau dann
gruppen gucken uns das noch mal gerade
an das rote soll jetzt der golfstrom
sein das ist das warme salzige wasser
das nach norden fließt und in der arktis
sinkt dieses wasser normalerweise ab
aber und fühlt sich oben ab da ja es
sind ja nach unten und fühlt sich dabei
aber dieser golfstrom wird immer
langsamer weil das wasser nicht mehr
schwer genug ist warum ist es nicht
schwer genug ist dann jetzt eine thermo
haltlinie zirkulation hat also was mit
temperatur und salzgehalt zu tun und da
das grönland eis schmilzt und auch das
meereis in der arktis da der
gleichzeitig mehr wasserdampf in der
luft haben und deswegen ist ja auch
stärker regnet und die flüsse mehr von
diesem regenwasser in den atlantik rhein
treiben wird das wasser immer süßer und
bleibt leichter und sind dann in der
arktis eben nicht ab das muss es aber
dringend tun in der arktis absingen denn
sonst kommt der warme golfstrom einfach
nicht hinterher
der stopp dann auch und das heißt diese
zirkulationspumpe die über den ganzen
atlantik geht die könnte irgendwann ins
stocken kommen und dann würden wir ein
ganz neues regime haben einen ganz neuen
zustand auf der erde
denn diese ganzen ozeanischen strömungen
der hing natürlich miteinander zusammen
also der atlantik ist ja nicht allein
auf der welt sondern gibt auch den in
den pazifik und das alles hat
auswirkungen auf die atmosphäre auf den
ozean und insofern müsste es uns
beunruhigen wenn wir hören aber es
könnte sein dass der golfstrom
vielleicht 100 jahren man weiß es nicht
wann ganz einfriert wenn wir so
weitermachen wie bisher das haben wir ja
gerade von dr otto gehört also es geht
immer um die frage wie wahrscheinlich
ist es aber zumindest haben wir jetzt
schon mal gesehen in dieser forschung
ist ist nicht unwahrscheinlich dass es
passiert und das meinst du sagst du zu
recht sollte und sorge machen ich schau
mal hier in die kommentare was du
vielleicht noch beantworten kannst also
es gibt von maximilian hug zum beispiel
eine frage klimawandel wird ja häufig
mit konsequenzen für unsere gesellschaft
in verbindung gebracht welche
erkenntnisse gibt es hinsichtlich der
konsequenzen für die tierwelt bezogen
auf ökosysteme ja sehr gute frage also
wenn es immer wärmer wird bedeutet das
natürlich auch dass die klimazonen nach
oben und nach norden wandern das heißt
für einige tiere die jetzt schon in
ihrem wohlfühlbereich sind wird es dann
einfach an die werden aussterben
korallen zum beispiel mehr klar aber ich
dachte jetzt er zum beispiel an alpine
formen wenn irgendwann da oben nichts
mehr ist dann sind werden die aussterben
ja tanzen auch tiere natürlich und die
die fische zum beispiel können natürlich
eine gewisse zeit weiter nach norden
ziehen wenn sie da bessere
lebensbedingungen finden aber irgendwann
ist auch da ende
wir merken das ja bei den vielen
invasiven arten die wir haben ambrosia
nur um mal eine zu nennen also sachen
die sich halt ausweiten weil eben das
klima sich so verändert dass wir
menschen darauf hier auch gar nicht mehr
so eingestellt sind oder uns daran
gewöhnen müssen an die neuen auch an die
neuen jahr negativen wie pollen zum
beispiel oder zecken auch die sich viel
weiter ausbreiten und uns belästigen
können also sind diese auswirkungen auf
flora und fauna haben auch ganz mit dem
menschen selbst zu tun und wie sie uns
beeinträchtigen können möchte ich sagen
ein anderer kommentar wo ich nicht weiß
ob wir den beantworten können weil das
ist schon relativ komplex und reimann
bollinger aber schon interessant es gibt
doch sicher einen zeitlichen versatz
zwischen der emission der treibhausgase
als
am boden nicht auspusten und ihrer
klimawirkung in der höhe kann man schon
sagen wie lange dieser zeitraum ist also
die sehr gelingt das dann quasi
hinterher
das weiß man sowieso das sind hier
mindestens mal 30 jahre das heißt also
auch wenn wir jetzt sofort stoppen
wissen wir dass die temperatur weiter
ansteigt und dieser zeitraum sind
ungefähr 30 jahre davon gehen wir immer
aus das heißt selbst bei bestem
verhalten jetzt sofort werden wir die
ergebnisse dessen ersten 30 jahren sehen
können ich habe gerade frau dr otto so
verstanden dass sie sagte wenn wir
aufhören dass die temperatur bleibt ist
er sie meint das ziel
sie meint und man kann dann diese zwei
grad noch erreichen ja wenn wir jetzt
sofort aufhören
und eins ist auch nochmal ganz wichtig
zu sagen jedes zehntel grad ich glaube
in seiner anmoderation hast du gesagt
kein grad mehr
nein kein zettel grad mehr selbst wenn
wir die globale temperaturerhöhung die
wir nicht mehr aufhalten können auch nur
um ein zehntel grad reduzieren können
mit unseren vernünftigen verhalten mit
politischen entwicklungen oder oder
verabredungen der der der der länder
untereinander
das ist schon etwas gewonnen eine frage
die auch immer wieder kommt von heike
was können wir denn als einzelner schon
machen gerade in deutschland dann wird
auch immer gesagt dass deutschland hier
nur zwei prozent der weltweiten klima
oder klimagas emissionen beiträgt und
das ist doch historisch schreibt sie
weiter allem also seit millionen jahren
die welt im klimawandel ist da kann mir
doch nichts dran ändern also haben wir
die eine frage was kann der einzelne in
deutschland daran ändern ist ja nicht
eigentlich viel zu machtlos ich denke in
der summe sind wir viele das ist die
sache mit der fuhr und die miss voll
holz geladen wird und wenn dann nur ein
holzscheit ist dann kann man's wegziehen
wenn da war ganz viele sind dann können
wir nicht mehr wegziehen
das ist genau das wenn wir in der summe
uns alle menschen gleich also uns einig
sind oder auch das ist fast so etwas wie
herdenimmunität also wenn wir 80 95 80
90 prozent menschen haben die uns
glauben und die die mit an dem einen
strang ziehen
und wenn die politiker mitmachen und die
industrien und wenn die entsprechenden
gesetze so sind dann können wir was
verändern natürlich und vor allen dingen
als industrienationen so sehe ich das
jedenfalls müssen wir mit gutem beispiel
voran gehen weil wir ja schon so viel
zerstört haben in anführungsstrichen
verschmutzt haben wir müssen dann eben
halt mit gutem beispiel voran gehen und
unser know-how das wir eventuell haben
exportieren an diejenigen die sich nicht
leisten könnten über können wir mal
einen blick werfen oft ganze die größten
verursacher von treibhausgasen gibt es
auch natürlich daten zu teilweise hinken
hinterher weil auch nicht alle länder
immer preisgeben was sie so ausstoßen
aber dort sehen wir auf platz eins china
daten von 2018 mit zehn über 10
millionen tonnen und ganz unten steht
deutschland auf dieser skala nicht auf
den gesamten länderliste sondern
irgendwann guckt platz sechs mit 759
millionen tonnen also gerade china
mittlerweile der größte emittent von co2
gasen
da gibt es bemühungen habe ich gelesen
dass zu reduzieren aber das kommt
relativ spät kommt spät aber trotzdem
musst du natürlich das eigentlich immer
pro kopf rechnen nicht also als wären es
gibt mehr chinesen als historische und
dafür ist dann diese deutsche summe
schon erschreckend hoch es gibt übrigens
im internet fertig das interessiert auch
ein rechner bei könnt ihr mal schauen
was eigentlich so euer durchschnittliche
co2 ausstoß pro jahr ist ich hatte das
wollte mal gemacht ich bin auf 10,8
tonnen pro jahr gekommen
damit liege ich ganz knapp unter dem
durchschnitt aber längst nicht so viel
wie ich dachte dass ich liegen würde
liegt unter anderem am main
mobilitätsverhalten was kann man danach
ändern genau es ist ganz abhängig davon
wie mein eigener lebensstil ist das war
auch die frage der userin hier glaube
ich noch die wissen wollte was kann ich
als einzelner denn tun
es gibt ganz viele menschen die können
ganz wenig tun weil sie vielleicht
sowieso schon in einer kleinen wohnung
wohnen sich sowieso öffentlich fort
bewegen und so weiter die haben die
können haben ein geringeres potenzial
einzusparen aber diejenigen die aus
welchen gründen immer jetzt ist das ja
corona bedingt gar nicht mehr nötig
gewesen durch die welt jetten und jetzt
langsam feststellen da man kann auch
vieles eben halt per video-konferenz
erledigen die spar natürlich viel mehr
ein oder auch unsere reiseverhalten und
unser ganz ganz allgemein unser
transport verhalten usw
also wir können eine ganze menge machen
auch
das ist ja immer sehr schwierig die
ernährung nehme ich auch mal gerne als
beispiel sich regional und saisonal zu
ernähren anstatt da irgendwelche
erdbeeren zu weihnachten kann fliegen zu
lassen
man kann eine ganze menge tun und zu
glauben mein einzelner beitrag ist zu
ist gering ist einfach wie soll ich
sagen macht keine gute laune also ist
besser zu sagen man meinen antrag ist
meinen eintrag meinen beitrag zu dem
ganzen ist relativ groß und das was ich
machen kann
das tut nichts desto trotz muss man
feststellen die größten emittenten ist
die industrie sind die großen
industrienationen und vielleicht mal
hier so an die adresse zum beispiel an
fix und foxi es geht nicht darum den
deutschen den einzelnen menschen hier
das ausatmen zu verbieten
das ist polemisch von dir das weiß ich
wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen
ironisch habe ich glaub ich ein bisschen
sachlichkeit zu bleiben so insgesamt in
chat wäre der sache zuträglich denn
insgesamt geht es hier ja glaube ich um
unseren lebensraum den wir möglichst
auch für unsere kommenden generation
erhalten sollten
katja ich danke dir dass du die fragen
für uns beantwortet hast wir werden über
dieses thema habe ich gerade schon
gesagt auch sehr oft reden es gibt viele
einzelne aspekte die für uns angucken
können und müssen
das werden wir auch tun mit euch hier
zusammen heute sage ich aber vielen dank
fürs zuschauen für eure kommentare und
fragen platz sachlich das zum nächsten
mal macht's gut
und tschüss